the joint session will come to order
the chair appoints as members of the
Committee on the part of the House to
escort the President of the United
States into the chamber the gentleman
from Maryland mr. Hoyer the gentleman
from South Carolina mr. Clyburn the
gentleman from New Mexico mr. Lujan the
gentleman from mr. Newark New York mr.
Jeffries the gentlewoman from
Massachusetts miss Clark the gentlewoman
from Illinois mrs. Bustos the
gentlewoman from California miss to the
gentlewoman from Kansas miss David's the
gentlewoman from New Mexico miss Holland
the gentleman from California mr.
McCarthy the gentleman from Louisiana
mr. Scalise the gentlewoman from Wyoming
miss Cheney the gentleman from Minnesota
mr. emmer the gentleman from Alabama mr.
Palmer the gentleman from North Carolina
mr. Walker the gentleman from Missouri
mr. Smith the gentleman from Texas mr.
Brady the gentleman from Oklahoma mr.
Cole
the president of the Senate of the
direction of that body appoints the
following senators as members of the
Committee on the part of the Senate to
escort the President of the United
States in the House chamber the senator
from Kentucky mr. McConnell the senator
from South Dakota mr. Thune
the senator from Iowa mr. Grassley
senator from Wyoming mr. Barasa senator
from Iowa miss Ernst the senator from
Missouri mr. Blunt the senator from
Indiana mr. young the senator from New
York mr. Schumer the senator from
Illinois mr. Durbin the senator from
Wisconsin miss Baldwin the senator from
Maryland mr. Cardin the senator from New
Hampshire
mrs. Shaheen and the senator from
Delaware mr. Coons Thank You mr. vice
president the members of the escort
committees will exit the chamber through
the speaker's lobbies doors
madam Speaker the Dean of the diplomatic
corps
[Applause]
good evening and welcome to quick take
by Bloomberg's coverage of President
Donald Trump's twenty20 State of the
Union address streaming live right now
on Twitter and YouTube I'm Viviana tato
in New York you're taking a live look
right now at the US House of
Representatives just a few weeks ago the
president became the 3rd
commander-in-chief in US history to be
impeached tonight though he'll address a
joint session of Congress which you see
right now
critically though he speaks to the
nation and with this speech one senior
administration official says will be
quote optimistic and forward-looking we
know the president will describe the
State of the Union as strong
specifically the economy is strong but
what will he highlight as he looks ahead
to the presidential election in November
joining me now to break that down and
much more is Bloomberg News Washington
bureau chief Craig Gordon he's not in
the nation's capitol but rather from the
capital of Iowa and Des Moines so Craig
we can talk a little bit what more why
you're still in Iowa but set the scene
very quickly for us for tonight's
address what's at stake for the
president I think it's a chance for
locally spent about three four weeks
with the impeachment proceedings first
in the house and then the trial in the
Senate where a lot of Democrats have
been saying not very nice things about
the president and his ethics especially
related to to the situation in Ukraine
there and I actually think this is a
chance for Trump to kind of remind
people who like him why they like him
he's a fighter he's going to come out
I'm sure and talk up all the
accomplishments that that he wants to
talk about in the campaign the good
economy job growth the the trade deals
with China and Mexico and Canada and all
of that stuff I think it's also a chance
for the president to talk to that very
slim but still very important amount of
voters who may be voted for him in 16
may be not loving everything they've
seen in the past three years some of the
tweets and some of the some of the
behavior and they kind of want to get
get another look at the
guy up close you know they're gonna have
an hour and change we think the hours of
the speech is pushing an hour and a half
to kind of see him remember why they
liked him maybe maybe you know relight
him again so I do think it's a chance
for him to reach out to some of those
people who may have soured on him a bit
to remind him why they might have come
with him in 2016 maybe come with him
again in 2020 and Craig just to let you
know for those who are following on
social media you're taking a live look
right now at California Senator Kamala
Harris who dropped out of the
presidential race a Democratic
nomination that is Craig I want to touch
on something that we mentioned about
earlier which is how really the theme is
going to be the great American comeback
that is very different from inauguration
where the president took the opportunity
that bully pulpit so to speak to speak
about the American karnage optimistic
uniting do you think Craig yeah I mean I
don't know that Donald Trump has the
ability to unite voters right now in the
United States you know it's it's easy to
see for the polls just how polarized our
people are right now so and a lot of the
reason for that polarization frankly is
Donald Trump so I think that would be a
lot to ask of him or to expect from him
tonight but it is an opportunity for him
to strike a different tone obviously we
all know the president is kind of a
pugilistic fellow he likes to take
swipes at people the the the nicknames
the name-calling a Twitter obviously
there this would be a chance for him to
look like a President to look like a
leader to stand in front of the
collective lawmakers of the United
States and and through the camera to the
voters of the United States and and
again look like their leader look like a
president look like a statesman look
like a person who is in command of the
you know the the largest most important
country on earth and is up to that job
now three years into a presidency you
know to have to remind people you're
still up to that job or wherever up to
that job you know maybe not exactly a
great place for him to be heading into
reelection but let's be honest he is he
is underwater as we say in politics
terms his approval rating is below 50%
although he did reach a new high at
Gallup just today 49% of the countries
approves of the job he's doing and I
think it's an opportunity for him again
to look like a president act like a
president talk like the president lead
like president you know and one of the
things that we can also talk about as we
take a live look right now in the
chamber and we do have in fact right now
First Lady Melania Trump entering the
chamber as she's going to be joined by
some guests in fact two guests are going
to be sitting in the special box that is
overlooking the chamber we just saw
Tiffany Trump and really the first you
can also tell you that the president of
Venezuela on why bill is there what can
you tell us about the symbolism of these
guests that we're going to see us seated
at the first lady's box sure I mean
usually this is a tradition they were
started I think regulars whoever started
that we're almost like each person in
the box or these sort of family or
people speaks to a specific theme that
the president wants to address we have a
couple of folks there from Philadelphia
who you know is meant to talk about
school there is there to talk about
school choice or to kind of represent
school choice obviously there's a
military family there's other folks you
know people with a person his brother in
China
so as the president talks about the
entire integration you can point to Jodi
and you know I'm going to just jump in
there really quickly because the person
is cabinet is entering the chamber we
see US Secretary of State Mike Pompeo we
also see Treasury Secretary Steve in
Venetian that gets me to the topic of
some of the I guess themes that we can
dig into let's start with the economy
yeah I mean look if I were Donald Trump
I'd use about 1 hour and 29 minutes of
my one hour and thirty minutes in the
speech to talk about the economy
everybody knows that you know usually
one of the most important determinations
of whether a president's going to get
reelected is what's the unemployment
rate what's the GDP what's the job
growth numbers look like and and all
those scores Donald Trump has actually
got quite a good story to tell
unemployment at a 50-year low job growth
you know solid through the early parts
of the end of 2019 early parts of 2020
you know the economy really is on an
upswing now you could have a
conversation about whether everybody is
benefiting from it equally there's a lot
of income inequality in this country we
all know that but you know top-line
numbers for sort of how Donald Trump
could argued that for the most people in
America things are the sky's are very
bright and you know presidents get to
take credit when this economy is good
they get blamed when the economy is bad
we could we all know that they only can
do so much to sort of change that but
look if you're the president when the
economy is good you have a very very
good chance of getting reelected and I
know that Donald Trump's campaign team
is betting and counting on the strong
economy to help Trump get over the
finish line in November 2020 despite
what some people might think about and
related to some of the more personal
behavior again some of the Twitter
activity and whatnot if the economy is
good
the Trump campaign belief people will
forgive of Trump all that other stuff
because they feel good about their
pocketbooks on their wallets Craigan
we're taking a live look right now at
the chamber there is a shot of women in
white these are some of the Democratic
women who are wearing white and who are
in the that way you know certainly
harkening back to the suffragette
movement equal equal rights but can you
talk to us a little bit
the gender gap we you just mentioned
that there are high approval rating
certainly today that the president is
enjoying on the economy he polls very
high and certainly there's a partisan to
subdivide polling very very high among
Republicans a little bit less though or
a lot less though depending on where you
are on the political spectrum among
independents moderates and Democrats but
talk to us about the gender BEC gap
because Craig it's grown yeah absolutely
and I think it's probably not too many
things the Democratic presidential
candidates in Donald Trump's campaign
would agree on but they probably would
agree on this suburban women are the
single most important sort of cohort in
the in the election and whoever wins the
majority of them wins the the lion's
share of them is likely to be the one
that wins the presidency one of my
favorite statistics to be most telling
statistics for 2016 was a Donald Trump
won 52 percent of white women and in
that election people may remember there
was a white woman on the ballot that was
running against him her name was Hillary
Clinton and yet he managed to get a
majority of these these white female
voters no they weren't all suburban
voters a lot but I do think that is that
is sort of the the key group that people
are talking about I think in the past
I've been called soccer moms I don't
know what we're gonna so someone will
come up with a clever name for them this
year but these are people that a lot of
whom went to Trump I think these are the
kind of people that are the most turned
off by some of his shall we say less
presidential behavior and if the
Democrats are working very hard to bring
them back over to the Democratic side
with sort of kitchen table issues Craig
I'm gonna just jump in here I'm just
gonna jump in here because I do believe
that we see the President of the United
States let's listen in
madam Speaker the President of the
United States
we see the president just actually the
grantees glad-handing and will do so for
a couple more minutes let's look back to
some of these domestic themes its
specifically let's talk about a couple
of the battles that the president has
had the last year certainly the last
three years on trade specifically on
China and as well as a Canada and Mexico
trade deal what do you think he's gonna
say about that tonight I'm thinking that
he's going to claim victory Oh 100% and
I thought he was fond of saying
and he would talk about jobs jobs jobs
and that's what he's going to talk about
tonight I'm sure as he talks about the
phase one China trade deal and also the
redone NAFTA deal called non-aggressive
so of course you know he will he will
say first of all that in the case of
China you know that the Chinese in his
view or country in the United States and
fairly and he was able to reset that
relationship in a way that will argue
that benefits the American farmer and
American worker as say MacKinnon and in
Mexico he felt called that the work
deals ever cut and he felt like you kind
of reset that to the advantage of the
American worker and look we can debate
around the edges of these things but
those were two very big swings at the
bat you know he the China trade deal
seemed very very far from getting done
and then suddenly sort of came together
us MCA also pretty tough negotiating
there and he's - he's two for two on
getting trade deals done you know I
don't think people go to the polls
thinking about trade deals with a dude
or the poles thinking about jobs and he
can say to me
humph works like promise right I just
want to totally the president is
standing at the lectern Nancy Pelosi is
behind them as is his vice president
Mike Pence well is that a little bit
awkward given that it is Nancy Pelosi
chamber that impeach the president sure
I mean you know the symbolism it cannot
be overstated here you know not just a
few weeks ago visa this is the very room
where Donald Trump became the third
United States President and all of
history to be impeached some three weeks
later he's about to give a big speech
here and you know and maybe Nancy
Pelosi's house but for one night Donald
Trump kind of owns the room
and he has a chance to really put his
message out to the people in that room
but really it's the people watching out
in the country that are watching this
you know it's a powerful moment it's one
of the nights where the symbolism and
then sort of the majesty of American
democracy comes together whatever you
think of Donald Trump Nancy Pelosi or
Mike Pence these are the leaders of our
country they're on display for us we're
gonna get to see them up close it's an
amazing
[Applause]
thank you very much
madam speaker mr. vice president members
of Congress the first lady of the United
States
at my fellow-citizens three years ago we
launched the great American comeback
tonight I stand before you to share the
incredible results jobs are booming
incomes are soaring
poverty is plummeting crime is falling
confidence is surging and our country is
thriving and highly respected again
America's enemies are on the run
America's fortunes are on the rise in
America's future is blazing bright the
years of economic decay are over
the days of our country being used taken
advantage of and even scorned by other
nations are long behind us Ganju are the
broken promises jobless recoveries tired
platitudes and constant excuses for the
depletion of American wealth power and
prestige in just three short years we
have shattered the mentality of American
decline and we have rejected the
downsizing of Americans destiny we have
totally rejected the downsizing we're
moving forward at a pace that was
unimaginable just a short time ago
and we are never ever going back
[Applause]
I am thrilled to report to you tonight
that our economy is the best it has ever
been our military is completely rebuilt
with its power being unmatched anywhere
in the world and it's not even close our
borders are secure our families are
flourishing our values are renewed our
pride is restored and for all of these
reasons I say to the people of our great
country and to the members of Congress
the state of our union is stronger than
ever before
the vision I will lay out this evening
demonstrates how we are building the
world's most prosperous and inclusive
society one where every citizen can join
in America's unparalleled success and
where every community can take part in
America's extraordinary rise from the
instant I took office I moved rapidly to
revive the US economy slashing a record
number of job-killing regulations
enacting historic and record-setting tax
cuts and fighting for fair and
reciprocal trade agreements
our agenda is relentlessly pro-worker
pro-family pro-growth and most of all
pro-american
thank you we are advancing with
unbridled optimism and lifting our
citizens of every race color religion
and Creed very very high since my
election we have created 7 million new
jobs 5 million more than government
experts projected during the previous
administration
the unemployment rate is the lowest in
over half a century and very incredibly
the average unemployment rate under my
administration is lower than any
Administration in the history of our
country
if we hadn't reversed the failed
economic policies of the previous
administration the world would not now
be witnessing this great economic
success
the unemployment rate for
african-americans Hispanic Americans and
Asian Americans has reached the lowest
levels in history
african-american youth unemployment has
reached an all-time low
african-american poverty has declined to
the lowest rate ever recorded the
unemployment rate for women reached the
lowest level in almost 70 years and last
year women filled 72 percent of all new
jobs added
the veterans unemployment rate dropped
to a record low
the unemployment rate for disabled
Americans has reached an all-time low
workers without a high school diploma
have achieved the lowest unemployment
rate recorded in US history
a record number of young Americans are
now employed under the last
administration more than 10 million
people were added to the Food Stamp
rolls under my administration seven
million Americans have come off food
stamps and ten million people have been
lifted off of welfare
in eight years under the last
administration over 300,000 working age
people dropped out of the workforce in
just three years of my administration
3.5 million people working age people
have joined the workforce
since my election the net worth of the
bottom half of wage earners has
increased by 47 percent three times
faster than the increase for the top one
percent
after decades of flat and falling
incomes wages are rising fast and
wonderfully they are rising fastest for
low-income workers who have seen a 16
percent pay increase since my election
this is a blue-collar boom
real median household income is now at
the highest level ever recorded since my
election US stock markets have soared
70% adding more than 12 trillion dollars
to our nation's wealth transcending
anything anyone believed was possible
this is a record it is something that
every country in the world is looking up
to they admire consumer confidence has
just reached amazing new highs all of
those millions of people with 401ks and
pensions are doing far better than they
have ever done before with increases of
60 70 80 90 and 100% and even more jobs
and investments are pouring in to nine
thousand previously neglected
neighborhoods
thanks to Opportunity Zones a plan
spearheaded by Senator Tim Scott as
Republican
in other words wealthy people and
companies are pouring money into poor
neighborhoods or areas that haven't seen
investment in many decades creating jobs
energy and excitement
this is the first time that these
deserving communities have seen anything
like this it's all working Opportunity
Zones are helping Americans like Army
veteran tony Rankin's from Cincinnati
Ohio after struggling with drug
addiction Tony lost his job his house
and his family he was homeless but then
Tony found a construction company that
invests in opportunities zones he is now
a top tradesman drug-free reunited with
his family and he is here tonight Tony
keep up the great work Tony
thank you Tony our roaring economy has
for the first time ever given many
former prisoners the ability to get a
great job and a fresh start the second
chance at life is made possible because
we passed landmark criminal justice
reform into law everybody said that
criminal justice reform couldn't be done
but I got it done and the people in this
room got it done
[Applause]
thanks to our bold regulatory reduction
campaign the United States has become
the number-one producer of oil and
natural gas anywhere in the world
with the tremendous progress we have
made over the past three years America
is now energy independent and energy
jobs like so many other elements of our
country are at a record high
we are doing numbers that no one would
have thought possible just three years
ago likewise we are restoring our
nation's manufacturing might even though
predictions were as you all know that
this could never ever be done after
losing 60,000 factories under the
previous two administrations America has
now gained 12,000 new factories under my
administration with thousands upon
thousands of plants and factories being
planned or being built
companies are not leaving they are
coming back to the USA
the fact is that everybody wants to be
where the action is in the United States
of America is indeed the place where the
action is one of the biggest promises I
made to the American people was to
replace the disastrous NAFTA trade deal
in fact unfair trade is perhaps the
single biggest reason that I decided to
run for president following NAFTA's
adoption our nation lost one in four
manufacturing jobs many politicians came
and went pledging to change or replace
NAFTA only to do so and then absolutely
nothing happened but unlike so many who
came before me I keep my promises we did
our job
six days ago i replaced nafta and signed
the brand new US mexico canada agreement
into law the u.s. MCA will create nearly
100,000 new high-paying american auto
jobs and massively boost exports for our
farmers ranchers and factory workers it
will also bring trade with mexico and
canada to a much higher level but also
to be a much greater degree of fairness
and reciprocity we will have that
fairness and reciprocity and I say that
finally because it's been many many
years that we were treated fairly on
trade this is the first major trade deal
in many years to earn the strong backing
of America's labor unions I also
promised our citizens that I would
impose tariffs to confront China's
massive theft of America's jobs our
strategy has worked days ago we signed
the groundbreaking new agreement with
China that will defend our workers
protect our intellectual property bring
billions and billions of dollars into
our treasury and open vast new markets
for products made and grown right here
in the USA
for decades China has taken advantage of
the United States now we have changed
that but at the same time we have
perhaps the best relationship we've ever
had with China including with President
Xi they respect what we've done because
quite frankly they could never really
believe that they were able to get away
with what they were doing
year after year decade after decade
without someone in our country stepping
up and saying that's enough
now we want to rebuild our country and
that's exactly what we're doing
we are rebuilding our country as we
restore American leadership throughout
the world we are once again standing up
for freedom in our hemisphere that's why
my administration reversed the failing
policies of the previous administration
on Cuba
we are supporting the hopes of Cubans
Nicaraguans and Venezuelans to restore
democracy the United States is leading a
59 Nation diplomatic coalition against
the socialist dictator of Venezuela
Nicolas Maduro
Maduro is an illegitimate ruler a tyrant
who brutalizes his people but medoras
Gripen tyranny will be smashed and
broken here this evening it's a very
brave man who carries with him the hopes
dreams and aspirations of all
Venezuelans joining us in the gallery is
the true and legitimate president of
Venezuela Juan Guido mr. president
please take this message back kid
Thank You mr. president great honor
thank you very much
please take this message back that all
Americans are united with the Venezuelan
people in their righteous struggle for
freedom thank you very much mr.
president
[Applause]
thank you very much socialism destroys
nations but always remember freedom
unifies the soul to safeguard American
liberty we have invested a
record-breaking 2.2 trillion dollars in
the United States military
[Applause]
we have purchased the finest planes
missiles rocket ships and every other
form of military equipment and it's all
made right here in the USA
we are also getting our allies finally
to help pay their fair share
I have raised contributions from other
NATO members by more than 400 billion
dollars and the number of allies meeting
their minimum obligations has more than
doubled and just weeks ago for the first
time since President Truman established
the air force more than 70 years earlier
we created a brand new branch of the
United States Armed Forces
it's called the space force
[Applause]
in the gallery tonight we have a young
gentleman and what he wants so badly 13
years old in lawn Faye he's an eighth
grader from Arizona and please stand up
ian has always dreamed of going to space
he was the first in his class and among
the youngest at an aviation academy he
aspires to go to the Air Force Academy
and then he has his eye on the space
force as ian says most people look up at
space I want to look down on the world
but sitting behind Ian tonight is his
greatest hero of them all
Charles Magee was born in Cleveland Ohio
one century ago Charles is one of the
last surviving Tuskegee Airmen the first
black fighter pilots and he also happens
to be Ian's great-grandfather
[Applause]
credible story after more than 130
combat missions in World War two he came
back home to a country still struggling
for civil rights and went on to serve
America in Korea and Vietnam on December
7th Charles celebrated his 100th
birthday
a few weeks ago assigned a bill
promoting Charles McGee to Brigadier
General and earlier today I pinned the
stars on his shoulders in the Oval
Office
general McGee our nation salutes you
thank you sir
from the pilgrims to the founders from
the soldiers at Valley Forge to the
marchers at Selma and from President
Lincoln to the Reverend Martin Luther
King Americans have always rejected
limits on our children's future members
of Congress we must never forget that
the only victories that matter in
Washington are victories that deliver
for the American people
the people are the heart of our country
their dreams are the soul of our country
and their love is what powers and
sustains our country we must always
remember that our job is to put America
first
the next step forward in building an
inclusive society is making sure that
every young American gets a great
education and the opportunity to achieve
the American dream
yet for too long countless American
children have been trapped in failing
government schools to rescue these
students 18 states have created school
choice in the form of opportunity
scholarships the programs are so popular
that tens of thousands of students
remain on a waiting list one of those
students is Jenaya davis a fourth grader
from philadelphia Jenaya
[Applause]
denies mom stephanie is a single parent
she would do anything to give her
daughter a better future but last year
that future was put further out of reach
when Pennsylvania's governor vetoed
legislation to expand school choice to
50,000 children janilla and Stephanie
are in the gallery Stephanie thank you
so much for being here with your
beautiful daughter thank you very much
but you know I have some good news for
you because I am pleased to inform you
that your long wait is over I can
proudly announce tonight that an
opportunity scholarship has become
available it's going to you and you will
soon be heading to the school of your
choice
now I call on Congress to give 1 million
American children the same opportunity
janilla has just received passed the
education freedom scholarships and
opportunities act because no parent
should be forced to send their child to
a failing government school
every young person should have a safe
and secure environment in which to learn
and to grow for this reason our
magnificent first lady has launched the
b-best initiative to advance a safe
healthy supportive and drug-free life
for the next generation online in school
and in our communities Thank You Melania
for your extraordinary love and profound
care for America's children thank you
very much
my administration is determined to give
our citizens the opportunities they need
regardless of age or background through
our pledge to American workers over 400
companies will also provide new jobs and
education opportunities to almost 15
million Americans my budget also
contains an exciting vision for our
nation's high schools tonight I ask
Congress to support our students and
backed my plan to offer vocational and
technical education in every single high
school in America
to expand equal opportunity I am also
proud that we achieved record and
permanent funding for our nation's
historically black colleges and
universities
a good life for American families also
requires the most affordable innovative
and high quality health care system on
earth before I took office health
insurance premiums had more than doubled
in just five years I move quickly to
provide affordable alternatives our new
plans are up to 60% less expensive and
better
I've also made an ironclad pledge to
American families we will always protect
patients with pre-existing conditions
and we will always protect your Medicare
and we will always protect your Social
Security always
the American patient should never be
blindsided by medical bills that is why
I signed an executive order requiring
price transparency
many experts believe that transparency
which will go into full effect at the
beginning of next year will be even
bigger than health care reform it will
save families massive amounts of money
for substantially better care but as we
work to improve Americans health care
there are those who want to take away
your health care take away your doctor
and abolish private insurance entirely
132 lawmakers in this room have endorsed
legislation to impose a socialist
takeover of our health care system
wiping out the private health insurance
plans of 180 million very happy
Americans to those watching at home
tonight I want you to know we will never
let socialism destroy American health
care
over 130 legislators in this chamber
have endorsed legislation that would
bankrupt our nation by providing free
taxpayer-funded health care to millions
of illegal aliens forcing taxpayers to
subsidize free care for anyone in the
world who unlawfully crosses our borders
these proposals would raid the Medicare
benefits of our seniors and that our
seniors depend on while acting as a
powerful lure for illegal immigration
that is what is happening in California
and other states their systems are
totally out of control
costing taxpayers vast and unaffordable
amounts of money if forcing American
taxpayers to provide unlimited free
health care to illegal aliens sounds
fair to you then stand with the radical
left but if you believe that we should
defend American patients and American
seniors then stand with me and pass
legislation to prohibit free government
health care for illegal aliens
this will be a tremendous boon to our
already very strongly guarded southern
border where as we speak a long tall and
very powerful wall is being built
[Applause]
we have now completed over 100 miles and
have over 500 miles fully completed in a
very short period of time early next
year we will have substantially more
than 500 miles completed my
administration has also taken on the big
pharmaceutical companies we have
approved a record number of affordable
generic drugs and medicines are being
approved by the FDA at a faster clip
than ever before
and I was pleased to announce last year
that for the first time in 51 years the
costs of prescription drugs actually
went down
and working together Congress can reduce
drug prices substantially from current
levels I've been speaking to Senator
Chuck Grassley of Iowa and others in
Congress in order to get something on
drug pricing done and done quickly and
properly
I'm calling for bipartisan legislation
that achieves the goal of dramatically
lowering prescription drug prices get a
bill on my desk and I will sign it into
law immediately
[Applause]
with unyielding commitment
we are curbing the opioid epidemic drug
overdose deaths declined for the first
time in nearly 30 years among the states
hardest hit Ohio is down 22%
Pennsylvania is down 18% Wisconsin is
down 10% and we will not quit until we
have beaten the opioid epidemic once and
for all
protecting Americans health also means
fighting infectious diseases we are
coordinating with the Chinese government
and working closely together on the
corona virus outbreak in China my
administration will take all necessary
steps to safeguard our citizens from
this threat we have launched ambitious
new initiatives to substantially improve
care for Americans with kidney disease
Alzheimer's and those struggling with
mental health and because Congress were
so good as to fund my request new cures
for childhood cancer and we will
eradicate the AIDS epidemic in America
by the end of this decade
almost every American family knows the
pain when a loved one is diagnosed with
a serious illness here tonight is a
special man beloved by millions of
Americans who just received a stage four
advanced cancer diagnosis this is not
good news but what is good news is that
he is the greatest fighter and winner
that you will ever meet
rush limbaugh thank you for your decades
of tireless devotion to our country
and rush in recognition of all that you
have done for our nation the millions of
people a day that you speak to and that
you inspire and all of the incredible
work that you have done for charity I am
proud to announce tonight that you will
be receiving our country's highest
civilian honor the Presidential Medal of
Freedom
I will now ask the First Lady of the
United States to present you with the
honor please
[Applause]
[Music]
Russ and Catherine congratulations Thank
You Catherine as we pray for all who are
sick we know that America is constantly
achieving new medical breakthroughs in
2017 doctors at st. Luke's Hospital in
Kansas City delivered one of the
earliest premature babies ever to
survive born at just 21 weeks in six
days and weighing less than a pound
ellie schneider was a born fighter
through the skill of her doctors and the
prayers of her parents little ellie kept
on winning the battle of life today
ellie is a strong healthy two-year-old
girl sitting with her amazing mother
robin in the gallery ellie
and robin we are glad to have you with
us tonight
[Applause]
le reminds us that every child is a
miracle of life and thanks to modern
medical wonders 50% of very premature
babies delivered at the hospital where
le was born now survived it's an
incredible thing thank you very much
[Applause]
our goal should be to ensure that every
baby has the best chance to thrive and
grow just like le that is why I'm asking
Congress to provide an additional 50
million dollars to fund neonatal
research for America's youngest patients
that is why I'm also calling upon
members of Congress here tonight to pass
legislation finally banning the late
term abortion of baby
whether we're Republican Democrat or
independent surely we must all agree
that every human life is a sacred gift
from God as we support America's moms
and dads I was recently proud to sign
the law providing new parents in the
federal workforce paid family leave
serving as a model for the rest of the
country
now I call on Congress to pass the
bipartisan advancing support for working
families Act extending family leave to
mothers and fathers all across our
nation
40 million American families have an
average 2200 dollars extra thanks to our
child tax credit
I've also overseen historic funding
increases for high quality childcare
enabling 17 states to help more children
many of which have reduced or eliminated
their wait lists altogether and I sent
Congress a plan with a vision to further
expand access to high quality childcare
and urge you to act immediately to
protect the environment days ago I
announced that the United States will
join the 1 trillion trees initiative an
ambitious effort to bring together
government and private sector to plant
new trees in America and all around the
world
we must also rebuild America's
infrastructure
I asked you to pass senator John burrows
highway bill to invest in new roads
bridges and tunnels all across our land
I'm also committed to ensuring that
every citizen can have access to
high-speed Internet including and
especially in rural America
they better tomorrow for all Americans
also requires us to keep America safe
that means supporting the men and women
of law enforcement at every level
including our nation's heroic ice
officers
last year our brave vice officers
arrested more than 120,000 criminal
aliens charged with nearly 10,000
burglaries 5,000 sexual assaults 45,000
violent assaults and 2,000 murders
tragically there are many cities in
America where radical politicians have
chosen to provide sanctuary for these
criminal illegal aliens in sanctuary
cities local officials order police to
release dangerous criminal aliens to
prey upon the public instead of handing
them over to ice to be safely removed
just 29 days ago a criminal alien freed
by the sanctuary city of New York was
charged with the brutal rape and murder
of a 92 year old woman the killer had
been previously arrested for assault but
under New York sanctuary policies he was
set free if the city had honored ices
detainer request his victim would still
be alive today the state of California
passed an outrageous law declaring their
whole state to be a stink cheeri for
criminal illegal immigrants a very
terrible sanctuary with catastrophic
results here is just one tragic example
in December 2018 California police
detained an illegal alien with five
prior arrests including convictions for
robbery and assault
but as required by California sanctuary
law local authorities released him days
later the criminal alien went on a
gruesome spree of deadly violence he
viciously shot one man going about his
daily work he approached a woman sitting
in her car and shot her in the arm and
in the chest he walked into a
convenience store and wildly fired his
weapon he hijacked a truck and smashed
into vehicles critically injuring
innocent victims one of the victims is a
terrible terrible
situation died fifty one-year-old
American named rocky Jones rocky was at
a guest station when this vile criminal
fired eight bullets at him from close
range murdering him in cold blood
rocky left behind a devoted family
including his brothers who loved him
more than anything else in the world one
of his grieving brothers is here with us
tonight
Jodie would you please stand Jodie thank
you
Jodee our hearts weep for your loss and
we will not rest until you have justice
senator Tom Tillis has introduced
legislation to allow Americans like Jodi
to sue sanctuary cities and states when
a loved one is hurt or killed as a
result of these deadly practice
I asked Congress to pass the justice for
victims of sanctuary cities act
immediately the United States of America
should be a sanctuary for law-abiding
Americans not criminal aliens
in the last three years Isis arrested
over 5,000 wicked human traffickers and
I have signed nine pieces of legislation
to stamp out the Menace of human
trafficking domestically and all around
the globe my administration has
undertaken an unprecedented effort to
secure the southern border of the United
States
before I came into office if you showed
up illegally on our southern border and
were arrested you were simply released
and allowed into our country never to be
seen again
my administration has ended catch and
release
if you come illegally you will now be
promptly removed from our country very
importantly we entered into historic
cooperation agreements with the
governments of Mexico Honduras El
Salvador and Guatemala as a result of
our unprecedented efforts illegal
crossings are down 75% since May
dropping eight straight months in a row
and as the wall rapidly goes up drug
seizures rise and the border crossings
are going down and going down very
rapidly
last year our travel to the border in
Texas and met Chief Patrol agent Raul
Ortiz for months agent Ortiz and his
team have seized more than 200,000
pounds of poisonous narcotics arrested
more than 3,000 human smugglers and
rescued more than 2,000 migrants days
ago agent Ortiz was promoted to deputy
chief of Border Patrol and he joins us
tonight
chief Ortiz please stand
a grateful nation thanks you and all of
the heroes of border patrol and ice
thank you very much to build on these
historic gains we are working on
legislation to replace our outdated and
randomized immigration system with one
based on merit welcoming those who
follow the rules contribute to our
economy support themselves financially
and uphold our values
[Applause]
with every action my administration is
restoring the rule of law and
reasserting the culture of American
freedom working with Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell Thank You Mitch
and his colleagues in the Senate we have
confirmed a record number of 187 new
federal judges to uphold our
Constitution as written this includes
two brilliant new Supreme Court justices
Neil Gorsuch and Brett Kavanaugh thank
you
and we have many in the pipeline my
administration is also defending
religious liberty and that includes the
constitutional right to pray in public
schools
in America we don't punish prayer we
don't tear down crosses we don't ban
symbols of faith we don't muzzle
preachers and pastors in America we
celebrate faith we cherish religion we
lift our voices in prayer and we raise
our sights to the glory of God just as
we believe in the First Amendment we
also believe in another constitutional
right that is under siege all across our
country so long as I am president I will
always protect your Second Amendment
right to keep and bear arms
in reaffirming our heritage as a free
nation we must remember that America has
always been a frontier nation now we
must embrace the next frontier America's
manifest destiny and the Stars I am
asking Congress to fully fund the
Artemis program to ensure that the next
man and the first woman on the moon will
be American astronauts using this as a
launching pad to ensure that America is
the first nation to plant its flag on
Mars
my administration is also strongly
defending our national security and
combating radical Islamic terrorism
last week I announced a groundbreaking
plan for peace between Israel and the
Palestinians recognizing that all past
attempts have failed we must be
determined and creative in order to
stabilize the region and give millions
of young people the chance to realize a
better future three years ago the
barbarians of Isis held over 20,000
square miles of territory in Iraq and
Syria today the ISIS territorial
Caliphate has been 100% destroyed and
the founder and leader of Isis the
bloodthirsty killer known as al Baghdadi
is dead
we are joined this evening by Carl and
Marcia Muller after graduating from
college their beautiful daughter Cala
became a humanitarian aid worker she
once wrote some people find God in
church
some people find God in nature some
people find God in love I find God and
suffering I've known for some time what
my life's work is using my hands as
tools to relieve suffering in 2013 while
caring for suffering civilians in Syria
Kayla was kidnapped tortured and
enslaved by Isis and kept as a prisoner
of al Baghdadi himself after more than
500 horrifying days of captivity al
Baghdady murdered young beautiful Kayla
she was just 26 years old on the night
that US Special Forces operations ended
al Baghdadi's miserable life the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
general mark Milley received a call in
the Situation Room he was told that the
brave men of the elite Special Forces
team that so perfectly carried out the
operation had given their mission a name
Task Force 8:14 it was a reference to a
special day August 14th Kayla's birthday
Karl and Marcia America's warriors never
forgot Kayla and neither will we
every day America's men and women in
uniform demonstrate the infinite depth
of love that dwells in the human heart
one of these American heroes was Army
Staff Sergeant Christopher hake on his
second deployment to Iraq in 2008
sergeant hake wrote a letter to his
one-year-old son gage I will be with you
again he wrote to gage I will teach you
to ride your first bike build your first
sand box watch you play sports and see
you have kids also I love you son
take care of your mother I am always
with you daddy on Easter Sunday of 2008
Chris was out on patrol in Baghdad when
his Bradley Fighting Vehicle was hit by
a roadside bomb that night he made the
ultimate sacrifice for our country
sergeant Hague now rests an eternal
glory in Arlington and his wife Kelly is
in the gallery tonight joined by their
son who is now a 13 year old and doing
very very well - Kelly engage Chris will
live in our hearts forever he is looking
down on you now thank you
thank you very much thank you both very
much the terror is responsible for
killing sergeant hake was Kassim
soleimani
who provided the deadly roadside bomb
that took Chrissy's life Salamone was
the Iranian regime's most ruthless
butcher a monster who murder or wounded
thousands of American servicemembers in
Iraq as the world's top terrorists
allamani orchestrated the deaths of
countless men women and children he
directed the December dassault and went
on to assault US forces in Iraq was
actively planning new attacks when we
hit him very hard and that's why last
month at my direction the US military
executed a flawless precision strike
that killed Salamone and terminated his
evil reign of terror forever
our message to the terrorists is clear
you will never escape American justice
if you attack our citizens you forfeit
your life
in recent months we have seen proud
Iranians raised their voices against
their oppressive rulers the Iranian
regime must abandon its pursuit of
nuclear weapons stop spreading terror
death and destruction and start working
for the good of its own people because
of our powerful sanctions the Iranian
economy is doing very very poorly we can
help them make a very good and short
time recovery it can all go very quickly
but perhaps they are too proud or too
foolish to ask for that help we are here
let's see which road they choose it is
totally up to them
as we defend American lives we are
working to end America's wars in the
Middle East in Afghanistan the
determination and valor of our war
fighters has allowed us to make
tremendous progress in peace talks are
now under way I am NOT looking to kill
hundreds of thousands of people in
Afghanistan many of them totally
innocent it is also not our function to
serve other nations as law-enforcement
agencies these are war fighters that we
have the best in the world and they
either want to fight to win or not fight
at all we are working to finally end
America's longest war and bring our
troops back home
war places a heavy burden on our
nation's extraordinary military families
especially spouses like amy Williams
from Fort Bragg North Carolina and her
two children six-year-old Ileana and
three-year-old Rowan
Amy works full-time and volunteers
countless hours helping other military
families for the past seven months she
has done at all while her husband
sergeant first class Townsend Williams
is in Afghanistan on his fourth
deployment in the Middle East
Amy's kids haven't seen their father's
face in many months Amy your family
sacrifice makes it possible for all of
our families to live in safety and a
peace and we want to thank you thank you
Amy
but Amy there is one more thing tonight
we have a very special surprise I am
thrilled to inform you that your husband
is back from deployment he is here with
us tonight and we couldn't keep him
waiting any longer
[Applause]
welcome home sergeant Williams thank you
very much as the world bears witness
tonight America is a land of heroes this
is a place where greatness is born where
destinies are forged and where legends
come to life this is the home of Thomas
Edison and Teddy Roosevelt of many great
generals including Washington Pershing
Patton and MacArthur this is the home of
Abraham Lincoln Frederick Douglass
Amelia Earhart Harriet Tubman the Wright
brothers Neil Armstrong and so many more
this is the country where children learn
names like Wyatt Earp Davy Crockett and
Annie Oakley this is the place where the
Pilgrims landed at Plymouth and where
Texas Patriots made their last stand at
the Alamo the beautiful beautiful Alamo
the American nation was carved out of
the vast frontier by the toughest
strongest fiercest and most determined
men and women ever to walk on the face
of the earth our ancestors brave the
unknown tamed the wilderness settled the
Wild West lifted millions from poverty
disease and hunger vanquished tyranny
and fascism assured the world to new
heights of science and medicine laid
down the railroads dug out the canals
raised up the skyscrapers and ladies and
gentlemen our ancestors built the most
exceptional republic ever to exist in
all of human history and we are making
it greater than ever before
[Applause]
this is their glorious and magnificent
inheritance we are Americans we are
pioneers we are the Pathfinders we
settled a new world we built the modern
world and we change history forever by
embracing the eternal truth that
everyone is made equal by the hand of
Almighty God
[Applause]
America is the place where anything can
happen
America is the place where anyone can
rise and here on this land on this soil
on this continent the most incredible
dreams come true this nation is our
canvas and this country is our
masterpiece we look at tomorrow and see
unlimited frontiers just waiting to be
explored our brightest discoveries are
not yet known our most thrilling stories
are not yet told our grandest journeys
are not yet made the American age the
American epic the American adventure has
only just begun our spirit is still
young the Sun is still rising God's
grace is still shining and my fellow
Americans the best is yet to come
thank you and God bless
i'm viviana tato live in new york city
and I'm joined by Craig Gordon DC bureau
chief who's in Des Moines we're seeing
president Donald Trump finish his third
State of the Union as it knee the
chamber you know Craig I just wanted to
ask you he hit on a lot of stuff
beginning really with what I would call
a happy dance
you know trumping trumpeting all of
those economic victories but then he hit
really hard on immigration and it really
turned into kind of like a campaign
rally what are your thoughts on
differences exactly the first half of
the speech was a little more broad-based
the second half of the speech was
absolutely pure unadulterated appeared
to the Republican conservative base when
you are in the well of the house for the
State of the Union you're talking about
a bill on late term abortion talking
about praising immigration officials
talking about sanctuary cities giving a
medal a Presidential Medal to obviously
conservative talk show host Rush
Limbaugh obviously in a very tough
health shape but you know these are
these are pretty blatant appeals to your
to your conservative base and Trump
really did use the last half of the
speech to really make a pitch for his
reelection in 2020 and definitely we saw
the reaction from the chamber are there
any points Craig where you believe there
could be some reaching across the aisle
going forward this year I mean we are
just months away from the November
presidential election what would they be
yeah I got to be honest I didn't hear a
lot no what I don't want to be that
cynical but um you know there's sort of
the old chestnut that everyone loves to
talk about which is I'm sorry which is
infrastructure
you know refix fixing the roads and
bridges trillion dollars plans to do
that I know there were various bills
floating around Congress you know listen
Donald Trump's you know been the
president for three plus years he was
talking about doing an infrastructure
bill with the Democrats almost literally
on his first day in office never moved
an inch so you know
who we kidding here anyone who stayed
till the very end of the speech a pretty
long speech to my eyes about an hour and
a half watch Nancy Pelosi the Speaker of
the House the Democratic leader in that
room literally ripped the pages of the
speech and half I'm not sure I've ever
seen that before now in fairness Donald
Trump seemed to reject her outstretched
hand for a handshake at the beginning
you know at the beginning of the speech
too so if there's any question that
there's any love being you know shared
between the parties in that room you
could put that aside that was a campaign
speech designed to fire up the
Republican base make Democrats look like
they care about immigrants more than
they care about the American people care
about taking away your health care wanna
raise your taxes and and don't love the
military as much as Donald Trump them's
fighting words and look we're in an
election year so that's to be expected
to some extent you're taking a live look
at the US Congress chamber is emptying
out we're awaiting the Democratic
response that's going to be given by the
Democratic Michigan Governor Gretchen
Whitmer Kraig tell me what your thoughts
might be on an issue like health care
the president talked about that he also
talked about drug pricing we know that
that's really important particularly for
middle class voters
how do unify how do you get the Dems to
work on any kind of a proposal when it
could in fact imply dismantling
Obamacare yeah I mean look this is this
is the part where you know politics
isn't necessarily a dirty word
Republicans believe that the private
sector can can provide health insurance
and a competitive marketplace and give
good policy to people at a good price
and the competition will win out they
are you know what are capitalists and
they and they believe in that system
Democrats believe that that system works
for a lot of people who have private
insurance lucky enough to have a nice
insurance policy probably through their
employer but they feel them across field
if there's a lot of people that don't
get to take partake in that that that
really need a little bit of a government
assistance or a government style program
to get them the health care that you
know Americans deserve so that is
actually a very legitimate point of
contention between the two parties I
think it's going to be a central issue
in the political campaigns in the fall
and look the the person who finished
very strongly in the eye
caucuses last night where I'm sitting
here in Des Moines was Bernie Sanders so
far the early results have mayor people
to judge from South Bend Indiana number
one Bernie number two but I think you
know they both finished strongly enough
to go on strong to New Hampshire Bernie
Sanders wants to create something he
calls Medicare for all which was
essentially all but eliminate you know
private insurance over the long run and
replace it with sort of a government-run
program he has put a price tag on that
of thirty four trillion with a t
trillion dollars and that's his belief
he believes the government that's the
appropriate role for the government if
you have to raise taxes to do it you
should do it a lot of Republicans would
disagree with that and that's why we
have elections and that's why the
American people gets to choose between
the two parties so you know looking for
any kind of middle ground on health care
it's probably kind of a lost cause I
would argue that's okay there's a lot of
different ways to solve that problem the
two parties have very divergent opinions
about it let the voters decide let's go
to a term that the president used Craig
blue-collar boom if we were to move into
just the issue of the economy we know
that kitchen-table economics is what
really appeals to voters and what could
really be that winning issue for for a
candidate a reelection for this
president and this president is running
on a really strong record where if at
all do you think that Democratic
candidates Democratic hopefuls for
president are going to be able to get
you know dig in yeah look I think this
is this is probably the president's
strongest argument for reelection and
the one that is the hardest for the
Democrats to counter because you know
what he's talking about
you know blue-collar voters we know
that's term means kind of lower to
middle class middle class folks working
folks lunch-pail people you know
manufacturing workers that sort of that
sort of people good jobs raise a family
get insurance all those good things
those are a lot of Donald Trump support
came from came from folks like that and
we're gonna the reason we're gonna hear
from the governor of Michigan in a few
minutes here is because you know Auto
Workers that that's a that's a
working-class kind of a state Donald
Trump carried it he shouldn't have
frankly if the Democrats had done a
better job at 16 so the Democratic Party
to win the white house back needs to win
those blue-collar voters back I have not
heard a lot from the Democratic
candidates and
lord knows over 24 of them at one point
and we're down to it you know a smaller
handful now I I will say I have not
heard a lot from them that is
essentially better than what Trump is
offering them
Trump has results Democrats have
promises the voters are going to get to
decide there as well
Craig you were talking about Nancy
Pelosi tearing up the speech she wore a
pin as well that she wore during the
impeachment just in about 15 or 20
seconds
gridlock continues in Washington a
hundred percent I mean again anybody
watching that speech watching just even
you turn the sound down and just watch
the body language of the two sides the
two of the two leaders there the
president and the speaker these folks
are pretty far apart of that exchange
anytime soon and Craig right now we're
going to listen in to Michigan's
governor with school East Lansing high
school we're here today with families
and parents teachers and most
importantly students I want to thank you
all for coming but tonight I'm going to
talk to those of you who are watching at
home I'd made a lot more than 10 minutes
to respond to what the president just
said so instead of talking about what he
is saying I'm going to highlight what
Democrats are doing after all you can
listen to what someone says but to know
the truth watch what they do
Michigan errs are no different from
Americans everywhere we love our
families and want a good life today and
a better life tomorrow for our kids we
work hard and we expect our government
to work hard for us as well we have grit
and value loyalty and we still root for
the Detroit Lions we and all Americans
might be weary of today's politics but
we must stay engaged our country our
democracy our future demand it we're
capable of great things when we work
together we cannot forget that despite
the dishonesty and division of the last
few years and that we heard tonight from
the President of the United States
together we have boundless potential and
young Americans are proving that every
day by taking action that's
what I want to focus on tonight money
Scott is 13 years old and lives in
Muskegon Heights Michigan Monte Street
was covered in potholes they were
ankle-deep and he got tired of waiting
for them to get fixed so he grabbed a
shovel and a bucket of dirt and filled
them in himself during my campaign
people told me to fix the damn roads
because blown tires and broken
windshields are downright dangerous and
car repairs take money from rent child
care or groceries and we the Democrats
are doing something about it in Illinois
governor JB Pritzker passed a
multi-billion dollar plan to rebuild
their roads and bridges Governor Phil
Murphy is replacing lead pipes in New
Jersey all across the country Democratic
leaders are rebuilding bridges fixing
roads expanding broadband and cleaning
up drinking water everyone in this
country benefits when we invest in
infrastructure congressional Democrats
have presented proposals to keep us
moving forward but President Trump and
the Republicans in the Senate are
blocking the path when it comes to
infrastructure money has tried to do
more with a shovel and a pile of dirt
than the Republicans in DC have with the
Oval Office and the US Senate bullying
people on Twitter doesn't fix bridges it
burns them our energy should be used to
solve problems and it's true for health
care too for me for so many Americans
health care is personal not political
when I was 30 I became a member of the
Sandwich Generation that means I was
sandwiched between two generations of my
own family for whom I was the primary
caregiver
I was holding down a new job caring for
my newborn daughter as well as my mom at
the end of her brain cancer battle I was
up all night with a baby and during the
day I had to fight my mom's insurance
company when they wrongly denied her
coverage for chemotherapy it was hard it
exposed the harsh reality
of our workplaces our healthcare system
and our childcare system and it changed
me I lost patience for people who are
just talk and no action so as a state
senator I worked with a Republican
governor and legislature to expand
health care coverage to more than six
hundred eighty thousand Michiganders
under the Affordable Care Act today
Democrats from Maine to Montana are
expanding coverage and lowering costs in
Kansas governor Laura Kelley's working
across the aisle to bring Medicaid
coverage to tens of thousands in New
Mexico Governor Michelle Lujan Grisham
enshrined ACA protections into law every
Democrat running for president has a
plan to expand health care for all
Americans every one of them has
supported the Affordable Care Act with
coverage for people with pre-existing
conditions they may have different plans
but the goal is the same president Trump
sadly has a different plan he's asking
the courts to rip those life-saving
protections away it's pretty simple
Democrats are trying to make your health
care better Republicans in Washington
are trying to take it away think about
kids like 17 year old Blake Carroll from
Idaho who organized a fundraiser to pay
for his mom's colon cancer treatment
we're 19 year old Ebony Meyers from Utah
who sells art to help pay for her own
rare genetic disorder treatment no one
should have to crowdsource their health
care not in America but the reality is
not everyone in America has a job with
health care and benefits in fact many
have jobs that don't even pay enough to
cover their monthly expenses it doesn't
matter what the president says about the
stock market what matters is that
millions of people struggle to get by or
don't have enough money at the end of
the month after paying for
transportation student loans or
prescription drugs American workers are
hurting in my own state our neighbors in
Wisconsin and Ohio Pennsylvania all over
the country wages have stagnated while
CEO pay has sky
rocketed so when the president says the
economy is strong my question is strong
for hope strong for the wealthy who are
reaping rewards from tax cuts they don't
need the American economy needs to be a
different kind of strong strong for the
science teacher spending her own money
to buy supplies for her classroom strong
for the single mom picking up extra
hours so she can afford her daughter's
soccer cleats strong for the small
business owner who has to make payroll
at the end of the month Michigan
invented the middle class so we know if
the economy doesn't work for working
people it just doesn't work who fights
for working hardworking Americans
Democrats do in the US House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi and Democrats pass a
landmark bill on equal pay another bill
to give 30 million Americans are raised
by increasing the minimum wage and
groundbreaking legislation to finally
give Medicare the power to negotiate
lower drug prices for America's seniors
and families those three bills and more
than 275 other bipartisan bills are just
gathering dust on Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell's desk
Senator McConnell America needs you to
move those bills meanwhile Democrats
across the country are getting things
done Pennsylvania's Governor Tom Wolf's
is expanding the right to overtime pay
Michigan is too because if you're on the
clock you deserve to get paid
Nevada governor Steve's to select North
Carolina governor Roy Cooper are working
to give hard-working teachers arrays and
speaking of the classroom Wisconsin
governor Tony Evers unilaterally
increased school funding by 65 million
dollars last year in Colorado governor
jared Polis have an active free all-day
kindergarten and in 29 states we've
helped pass minimum wage hikes into law
which will lift people out of poverty
and improve lives for families
that's strength that's action democracy
action and that's why I'm so inspired by
young people they respond to mass
shootings demanding policies that make
schools safer they react to a world
that's literally on fire with fire in
their bellies to push leaders to finally
take action on climate change they take
on a road filled with potholes with a
shovel and some dirt it's what gives me
great confidence in our future and it's
why sometimes it feels like there be
adults in the room but it shouldn't have
to be that way it's not their mess to
clean up it's ours the choices we make
today create their reality tomorrow
young people I'm talking to you and your
parents and grandparents Democrats want
Safe Schools we want everyone to have a
path to a good life whether it's through
a union apprenticeship a community
college a four-year university without
drowning in debt we want your water to
be clean we want you to love who you
love and to live authentically as your
true selves and we want women to have
autonomy over our bodies we want our
country welcoming and everyone's vote
counted 2020 is a big year it's the year
my daughter Sheri will graduate from
high school it's also the year she'll
cast her first ballot along with
millions of young Americans the two
things are connected because walking
across a graduation stage is as
important as walking into the voting
booth for the first time her future all
our kids futures will be determined not
just by their dreams but by our actions
as we witness the impeachment process in
Washington there are some things each of
us no matter our party should demand the
truth matters facts matter and no one
should be above the law it's not what
those senators say tomorrow it's about
what they do that matters remember
listen to what P
we'll say but watch what they do it's
time for action
generations of Americans are counting on
us let's not let them down thank you for
listening god bless america
good night
you just heard the Democratic response a
Michigan Governor Gretchen Whitmer
delivering it and Lansing I also want to
note that freshman representative at
only guys go out of El Paso Texas is
delivering a response in Spanish Craig
what can you tell us your closing
thoughts are this was a very strong
Democratic response in particular I'm
just gonna note she said if the economy
doesn't work for working people it
doesn't work yeah look I think we all
just got introduced to a brand new
potential presidential candidate 2020
for 2028 I know it's hard to we're not
even through 2020 but obviously
incredibly poised very accomplished a
hugely important swing state in the
industrial Midwest Michigan and really
brought a lot to the table spent a lot
of time talking about health care which
people may remember Democrats kind of
won back the House of Representatives
made Nancy Pelosi the speaker we saw her
tonight on the issue of health care and
convincing voters that actually
essentially stick with Obamacare and
don't go with the Republican plans look
I'm the Trump side I have to say if
you're a Democratic operative or a
Democratic candidate watching the speech
tonight you should be a little bit
nervous he he had a good night as we
talked about at the beginning can he
look presidential can he sound
presidential can he look like a leader I
would argue that he did it was very it
was in a lot of ways very restrained for
a trump speech anybody who's seen some
of those epic news conferences where he
sort of goes off those don't always seem
terribly presidential to me tonight he
looked like the president up there
delivering a speech now he throw out a
lot of red meat for the conservative
base we talked about that earlier
sanctuary cities late term abortion some
of those issues but if he can if he can
find a way to thread that needle of
being looking presidential-sounding you
know like he's he's in command of the
job with the with the strong economy and
trade deals and whatnot
and combine that with a very aggressive
appeal to his conservative base boy I
think Democrats could have a little bit
of trouble stopping her from getting
reelected you know we know that the base
is fired up you were talking about that
certainly with the Medal of Freedom for
Rush Limbaugh but how about independence
how do you see the State of the Union
how does it move things with them yeah I
mean again the you know we in politics
everything is painted in such primary
colors and
there's not a lot of there's a lot of
red and a lot of blue not a lot of
purple if I were you know an independent
voter as I said at the beginning we're
watching for the people who maybe took a
chance on Trump in 2016 maybe not liking
everything they've seen but are kind of
tuning in to be like okay you know
tomorrow he's about to get acquitted in
his impeachment what's up with this guy
how's he doing what am i what am i
seeing I would see some things to like
there again the the speech the parts of
the speech about the economy no one can
dispute that jobs are being created you
know the economy is strong unemployment
soda at a low we can debate the quality
of those jobs we can play debate income
inequality and the wealth gap and
different things like that but the
bottom line facts and figures are kind
of in Trump's corner and if I'm if I'm
kind of thinking about the bottom line
facts and figures
he has a lot to he has a lot to offer
now this was one good night for him he
tends to do well in these bigger
speeches he tends to be kind of
restrained
it's very other very untrim like but to
the extent it's a big moment and a
chance for people to tune in I think he
gave he might remind them of the stuff
they liked about him and had less of the
stuff maybe they they get turned off by
Craig say the Union started off really
strong again happy dance on the economic
victories that this president can claim
how do you Democrat how do Democrats
fight this do you see that what governor
Whitmer was able to outline that the
candidates that are currently on the
trail right now and whomever becomes the
nominee just fine tunes that message
about stagnant wages tax breaks that
really benefited the rich and not the
middle class yeah those are exactly you
know they take the pocketbook issues you
know the issues the kitchen table issues
the Trump can win on and say hey not so
fast mr. president like yeah you know
what was the old joke from was what
Clinton's campaigns you know yeah I know
we're creating jobs because I have three
of them you know I'm not sure it's quite
as dire in 2020 as it might have been
back back during the recession in the
90s but yeah I don't I don't think
people are you know necessarily feeling
flush I think they're maybe not you know
they're feeling like the arrows in the
economy are pointed upward but there's
certainly a lot of people out there kind
of living on the bubble a little bit
those are the people that Democrats need
to talk to you know you can make a
pretty legitimate argument Donald Trump
builders tax plan to give rich people
tax cuts so it's just a fact that's just
that's not political rhetoric that's
what the numbers show so Democrats can
make some of those arguments a lot of
Democrats say they can they won in 18
and got the house back with health care
they need to be talking about it more in
2020 but there's kind of again how the
Democrats you know have a way of
shooting themselves in the foot Bernie
Sanders is not talking about Obamacare
he's talking about repealing Obamacare
and replacing with something much more
aggressive and much more expensive that
essentially eliminates you know for all
intents and purposes of living its
private insurance
I personally believe that's not a
winning argument for the American people
we had Nancy Pelosi in the Bloomberg
headquarters in November and she said my
friends my liberal friends in San
Francisco love Medicare for all out in
Michigan and Gretchen Whitmer home state
and the in the Midwest for the Democrat
have to win that is a losing argument
for us and if we push that we will lose
so you know the the Democrats have to
sort out their business do they want to
run a liberal like Bernie Sanders will
live with Warren go with a more moderate
choice like people who do judge Joe
Biden that's their fight they're having
right now we're gonna see a play out we
saw a play on I will see it New
Hampshire until they get their house in
order though they cannot marshal a
strong argument against Trump because
they're not speaking with one voice yet
that will happen when a nominee gets
picked who that nominee is is gonna be
hugely important to whether they have a
chance of dislodging Donald Trump for
the White House in 2020 and I have to
thank Craig Gordon Washington bureau
chief for Bloomberg News who's out in
Des Moines Iowa
honestly the original campaign Road
Warrior you're headed to DC on the way
to New Hampshire so many thanks to you
for joining me and I really want to
thank everyone out there who's been
joining us on Twitter and on YouTube
make sure to follow quick-take on
Twitter Facebook YouTube and Instagram
and for all of your insights and
analysis on tonight's speech check up a
politics page on Bloomberg comm I'm
Viviana tato live in New York good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]